we begin this half hour with the ripple
effect on school bus driver shortages on
schools students and families across the
country some states have gone as far as
calling in the national guard for help
among them is maryland where some of the
schools in the biggest district have
been forced to return to remote learning
errol barnett has more on the impact
from the nation's capital to the lone
star state parents remain under pressure
a lot of buses called out the ongoing
shortage of bus drivers already forced
schools in at least nine states to
request assistance from the national
guard but it's been more than two weeks
since maryland's biggest district sent
its own sos we've asked for 200. earl
started sent the signal they are still
inclined to try and help us but they're
looking for resources to do it in a
statement to cbs news maryland's
national guard says it's supporting the
state's department of health with
testing and other actions including
patient transport due to the current
covert surge there's just no certainty
about what will happen for mother of two
melissa ladd no guard means an
inconsistent bus schedule which has kept
her from substitute teaching
i haven't been able to assist the school
district in a time of great need and
staffing shortages all of this forcing
schools to recalculate bus routes every
24 hours it gives us very very little
room
to
make arrangements as the mother of two
teenagers eurania benicio faces
frustrating choices we have to be on
on site to be able to do our jobs
and it's either that or we stay home to
take care of our children as of thursday
16 montgomery county public schools went
virtual until at least the end of the
month as it sees record quarantine
numbers of staff and students who
officials acknowledge are struggling the
learning loss that we're now mitigating
from earlier
pandemic disruptions or earlier pandemic
virtual learning
is in many ways a significant amount of
work to make up for a lot of these
students for cbs saturday morning errol
barnett rockville maryland
listen when the national guard gets
called and you know it can be serious
right the challenges they've been
dealing with for two years now right